j'aimerais bien pouvoir être devant vous
aujourd'hui mais malheureusement nous
sommes en 2021 et pour l'instant nous
sommes qu'on finisse nous sommes toutes
et tous un peu nostalgique de c'est ce
qu'on appelle désormais à l'aimant de
d'avant au monde on pouvait sortir aller
au cinéma au théâtre aux conférences est
notamment allé au restaurant
j'aimerais vous demander de imaginer une
liste des chefs auxquels vous aimeriez
et découvrir la cuisine dans cette liste
y at il des noms des femmes je suis
persuadé qu'ils et la plupart d'entrés
vous a oublié ou tout simplement ne
connaît pas des noms des femmes chefs
malheureusement c'est en réalité il ya
un vrai problème en 2021
savez vous que seulement 5% des
restaurants étoilés aujourd'hui en
france appartiennent à des femmes chefs
de zf eux
mais les problèmes majeurs vient en fait
de la représentation les rôles qu'on
accorde aux femmes dansaient concerne
les discours de la cuisine
en général dans la télévision on envie
de toujours des hommes blancs pour
commenter au expliquer comment réaliser
un plat comme si l'autorité donc dans le
domaine culinaire appartenait seulement
au genre masculin
et pourtant ces mêmes chefs là ils sont
invités ne cesse de dire que la cuisine
est absolument inspiré des plats de leur
grand mère et de leur mère la femme dans
un rôle domestique qui cuisinent pour sa
famille comme nourricière mais
rassurez-vous vous savez bien qu'ils
aient des femmes cheffes existe c'est
seulement problème des représentations
la gastronomie c'est un mot qui est on
conjugue au féminin
et pourtant dans tout le vocabulaire de
la gastronomie c'est souvent les
masculins qui l'emportent sur les
féminines mais qu'est ce que c'est que
la gastronomie la gastronomie n'a pas
des gens hommes aux femmes peu importe
puisque la gastronomie à la implique il
yal englobe toutes les pratiques
techniques liés à la nourriture
tout homme et toute femme ont besoin de
boire et de manger mais la dégustation
de plats aux dents vers des vins pu nous
procurer des moments de grâce peut même
nous émouvoir touché profondément des
passions interne
combien de fois on s'est dit qu' on est
ému des 20 places ou même des vins vers
des vins l'art de la gastronomie est
aussi une arme noble qui peut identifier
plusieurs cultures et la france dans
tout ça est pour ainsi dire est que nous
donner mon entière comme les pays de la
gastronomie dans cet art noble les vins
en place privilégiée
en tant qu'île boissons sacré boissons
d'élévation il s'estime a fait
d'ailleurs rentré dans le monde de la
gastronomie car moi même je suis ce mail
hier un bon verre de vin de nous
transporter très loin peut décrire même
ladhuie via un terroir un millésime des
états d'âme il ya des vins qui nous font
pleurer parfois il ya les vins pour
aînés pour séduire des vins pour boire
entre amis il ya aussi les grands vins
des philosophies les vins qui nous élève
qui nous donne accès à des vérités les
vins qui nous permet d'être moins timide
qui libère la parole
enfin les vins est par excellence on
voit sont sacrés qui accompagne à
merveille un bon plat d'ailleurs on dit
souvent
qui parfois on peut les mariés ils les
instants de grâce dans la gastronomie on
les trouve souvent dans ces mariages là
moi en tant que ce mail hier j'ai les
privilèges tous les jours dans mon
restaurant d'accompagner ces moments de
grâce
ces moments d'élévation en proposant
l'interprétation des vins en s'accordant
avec des plats tout a commencé en 2013
avec rencontre j'ai ouvert mon premier
restaurant avec une jeune chef qui
s'appelle amélie darvaza qui à l'époque
avait seulement 23 ans à l'époque
c'était un modèle un peu atypiques comme
on a pu citer car les femmes dans la
gastronomie ont pas vraiment en place
établie on était deux femmes à créer en
affaires en paillis ou canal saint
martin amélie aux fourneaux et moi en
salle en tant que chef des salles est
sommelière cette expérience là nous nous
a énormément soudé et ça nous a fait
compris aussi qui est un trait femmes on
peut être sécurité en ce moment jugé
on n'est pas obligé d'être forcément
dans un rôle des solutions mais cette
expérience qui a duré cinq ans nous a
permis aussi d imaginer un monde d'après
de nous donner des épaules pour imaginer
un autre projet nos petites utopies à
nous à la fin 2017 nous sommes partis en
vacances dans le sud de la france
nous avons rencontré un univers qui
allait devenir notre univers on arrive
dans un petit village de seulement 150
habitants dans ces villages au
presbytère
pencher dans les montagnes du parc du
haut languedoc
seulement 150 habitants densité
presbytère en restaurant qui est en
vente depuis quelques années déjà et qui
ne trouve pas preneur avec ml ces jours
là à la fin 2017
on s'est dit c'est là on va créer notre
projet des rêves dans ce projet des
rêves
l'humain est au centre de tout et on
s'est dit aussi qu'il est genre n'a pas
d'importance
on doit se sentir bien en tant qu'ami en
tant que femme aussi dans un cadre
équilibré où tout le monde a un rôle à
jouer chacune chacune a sa place sans
trop d archi on se lève tous les jours
pour accomplir mission qui demande
énormément de rigueur des passions
comment ça c'est dos les plongeurs les
commis la cheffe la serveurs la
sommelière les jardiniers tout le monde
d'en rejouer dans le respect dans la
bienveillance dans l' équilibre
on privilégie dans ses projets des rêves
hosties tout ce qui est local on a un
potager qui on cultive en permaculture
il ya en biodynamie cette philosophie
qui est qui met un rapport les
organismes vivants et qui regardent le
ciel pour jardiner avec la lune ont fait
une cueillette à chaque service pour que
tout soit extrêmement frais pour que les
vivants soit là qui vibre dans les
assiettes et amélie va compose d'une
petite histoire en petit narration dans
son menu dégustation mois gérant princen
pour accompagner ces plats raconter ses
histoires
est accordée chaque plat avec un verre
de vin dans un petit cadre où il ya
seulement quinze convives comme une
petite maison on accueille les clients
comme une grande famille
ça aussi ça fait partie du projet des
rêves pas de volume mais qualité par la
quête obsessionnelle du profit mais on
pour un projet durable débute est temps
de s'inscrire dans quelque chose qui
peut être autosuffisants c'est souffrir
à elle-même ça vous paraît un peu au
topic
dit comme ça je vous la corde les faits
tels qu'ils nous avons ouvert ses
restaurants y au bout de seulement six
mois
nous avons été récompensés par une
étoile au guide michelin
cette étoile là nous a fait rentrer dans
la petite italie stick des 5% des femmes
chefs étoilés il ça nous a donné aussi
courage et visibilité
nous avons même les marques et qui est
de plus en plus on autant d occasions d
parler dé prendre la parole et nous
croyons qui à chaque fois qu'on prend la
parole on risque d'être entendu chaque
fois qu'on prend la parole en tant que
femme dans un cadre minoritaires on a
quand même un rôle à jouer parce qu'il
ya quand on prend la parole on peut être
entendu il quand on a entendu on
s'inscrit et dans un narratif historique
et on sait ô combien on a besoin des
risques historique à la première
personne du féminin
enfin pour conclure les années 20 de
notre siècle seront des années très
important des années on va amortir des
changements un profond il est temps de
finir avec les patriarcats
l'exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
l'exploitation déchaîné des ressources
naturelles nous avons toutes et tous un
rôle très important à jouer
c'est important aujourd'hui dans le
monde dès demain dans ce monde d'après
dont on parle tant des trains conscience
d'être un créé dans le moment présent
d'abattre toutes les paradigmes jusque
là établi de créer un monde virtuel non
genre et où on mange en conscience où on
respecte les cycles de la nature où on
travaille avec tout ce qui est local
enfin le monde de demain est par
définition aux amandes engagé il nous
avons toutes et tous un rôle à jouer
dans cet engagement